[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning jeff
bezos didn't justify
gravity on his own when he blasted off
into space you could say
this was a family affair he was there
with his brother mark
who joined him on the journey of a
lifetime we spoke to them after they
landed and they told us
this is a dream look at that happiness
that goes
way back in high school your class
valedictorian of course you were getting
better
of course right in your speech um at
class valedictorian you were talking
about colonizing space
do you remember the last line of your
speech space the final frontier meet me
there you guys did that yeah we did what
was that like
did you have a moment where you looked
at each other i saw the high mom signs
whose idea was that
that was mark's idea i helped execute
yeah here's
here's see this is it says wow hint of a
high
wow it says wow now but if i'm upside
down in zero g
it says mom okay mark what you said in
the press conference you said it was
more emotional than you thought it was
going to be
the reason why that struck me is because
i felt that too mark and then i figured
out it's because i was afraid
why were you so emotional um i i imagine
that there was some of that in there i
know that before we went to the
um the launch pad we all had some
moments to
um sort of get our heads uh straight
before we left the the training center
and i actually took a minute and uh went
into the
crew capsule yeah and just sort of
closed my eyes and
you know i was thinking about my kids
yeah and
you know i i know how inherently safe
this vehicle is
how much work has gone into it the
redundancies all of the safety systems
but at the end of the day there's still
risk involved jeff
you had said all along you were not
afraid you were not nervous
and i'm thinking traveling at 2233 miles
an hour
breaking through doesn't scare you what
does scare you
well i i have i wasn't nervous i really
wasn't even so i kept thinking i'll be
nervous the morning of and then i'll be
nervous right ahead of launch and it
never really happened
but i know exactly that emotion you're
talking about
i felt it reflected from my kids and my
mom
and my dad all whom were nervous for us
yes
they were afraid i could see that no
matter what we did to try and settle
them down and calm them and
we really couldn't get there and then to
see their relief
they were you know more tearful after we
landed and came out the
capsule that's when they really broke
down yeah
and they were just so relieved and they
could finally
let it all out your mom was the first
one you hugged when you got off
was there clearly it's a bonding moment
for the two of you did you have a moment
with the two of you
up there we did my brother and i were we
picked seats so that we could see each
other from our seats
so we could look over and and and we had
we did you sit in the jeff bezos chair
okay
i'm gonna sit in chair number five we
got a chance to see what those seats
were like
the bezos brothers gave me a ground
level view of their training capsule
i think we were a little surprised by
how intense the
g-forces were on you know the kind of
ascent you know your
skin's all being pulled back into your
face and you're pushed into your seat
mark they tried to do a a comms check or
a status check with mark while we were
at max g's on return
yeah it was just bad timing though by
the time it got to you know they went
through oliver and wally by the time it
got to me
we were at five g's which is what it
said right here and they were like you
know astronaut mark how are you doing i
was
like
[Music]
i had a hard time responding to that one
so what's next because jeff you don't
have to do anything
but you choose to do one of the hardest
things well
you you do the things that you're
passionate about gail
if you're lucky in life you know you can
have a job you can have a career if
you're really lucky you get to have a
calling
i want people to know that besides being
a successful businessman you are still a
volunteer firefighter
and you did a ted talk people have to
look at it it's about kindness
but jeff said since you already have the
kindness gene
you already have the success gene he
said that this
changed him how did it change you
i think that i'm still processing a lot
of that
um but i will tell you in the um
in the best sense i've never felt
smaller
than i did today and it was and
it was um just an incredibly
humbling and beautiful sense of
personal scale right that i am such a
small part of all of this
i know look at the earth up there and it
will make you more humble
yeah i can't imagine what it was like i
thought it was great that we got to go
in that capsule together i call that a
basil sandwich i go
look at us guys we're basil sandwiches
i'm the filling nope i would call it
that but okay
no i thought that was funny they thought
it was funny too vlad all right
but listen you know there's been a lot
of talk about all the money that was
spent and
how he's you know how he spends his
money i love people trying to tell him
how to spend his own money
but yesterday he did something that was
also jaw-dropping it sure was
courage and civility award that's
getting lost in this coverage of the
of the space launch which is monumental
but he gave the courage and civility
award the first
to two people van jones and chef jose
andres
and it's to give to them to distribute
to charities and non-profits of their
choice
singling out people that he thinks are
doing hard work and doing it with
civility
it was jaw-dropping and he gave them a
hundred million
did i not say that part number no yeah
thank you anthony millions
that was a jaw-dropping part and they
can do whatever they want
yes no strings attached you two decide
how the money is best spent you know van
has done a lot of work with criminal
justice reform successfully
we know jose's chef jose's work and you
know in feeding
feeding the hungry and going into
emergency situations
but i just thought i love jeff bezos's
point you can do both
you can look to the future and you can
look to what's happening here and you
can do both
and do good things and they certainly
are doing that they really really are